If you guys were together for
a year and you haven't said it.
Break up. You're right.
Like break up. That's crazy.
Yeah, I was telling a story.
Like, I was with a guy
for a year
and I was just waiting
for him to say "I love you."
I knew he did by his actions.
Like, the way he high
fived me after sex but-
Chris Redd is here
everyone from SNL
and the movie "Pop Star"
which is my favorite comedy
movie in the past decade,
I would say.
He had such a fucking funny
stand-up.
And yeah.
Jesus Christ. That's dope.
Well, Chris Redd,
you're killing it on SNL.
Yeah, dude.
Hey, man.
Kanye. Oh my God.
Just 'cause your on SNL doesn't
mean you're gonna kill it.
We've seen so many times
people come and go
and I remember
when you got it.
I was just like
"I hope he makes a splash."
And you certainly have.
I mean, you are going to have
such longevity on that show
if you want it
and in your career.
You've always been talented
but it's just so nice
to see people acknowledging it.
What is it like
being over there?
Are you still frightened every
time you walk in the building?
Nah.
I mean, it had to started
that way.
Were you so intimidated?
I wasn't really intimidated
by Lorne or the show.
It's just, I learned how much
anxiety I actually have,
which is crazy 'cause there's
so much pressure to it.
Then there's like the people
that get to have opinions
about your work all the time
.
Yeah.
And I wasn't really used to that
but I'm very curious to know-
Do you mean
Twitter or producers?
Yeah, Every.
Internet, everything.
Okay.
Do you read that shit?
Yeah.
Dude.
I'm an insane person, Bro.
I do too. It's alright.
Nah, I tried.
I know it's not good for me.
You're [crosstalk]
so much.
I'm surprised you have time
to even see it.
First of all, if you're on
the show a lot to people.
It's only three sketches.
Right.
So, the rest of the time
I'm sitting there watching
the show with everybody else
and I'm just on Twitter
seeing what's hit
and seeing what's not.
Right. Interesting.
It's kind of like
being on stage.
You hear those laughs,
like I know this joke's working.
That's how it feels 'cause
every Saturday you're trending
unless there's somebody
on there that no one knows.
Then you're and the trend's
after the fact which is weird.
But you can see exactly
how things are hitting,
like immediately.
So, I'm all interested in that.
Do you like that or are you
like this is bad for me?
I kinda like it
and I kinda hate it.
Yeah.
I know it's bad.
But, I kinda like it
when it's going well.
It's like overwhelmingly
positive though, right?
Oh, yeah.
'Cause you're killing it
on there.
Yeah, but it's like
everything else.
I focus on the one guy.
Of course.
The one egg thing.
Flappyballsack72.
Like, this mother
fucking egg avatar.
I let it go though.
I was in a bad place
when I made that account.
Okay?
I was a little jealous.
I feel like that show's
never acknowledged me
or asked me
to audition and-
I think it's bullshit.
I bring you up all the time.
Your Kanye was fantastic and
that wasn't an easy role to do.
How did you prepare for that?
Well, they told me I was gonna
do it on Friday.
Friday morning.
That's great 'cause it's like,
I only have this amount of time,
I can't over think it.
Yeah.
What do you do?
When you do shit like that
it works out better.
Do you start googling?
Do you just start
watching videos?
Well, I'm like a huge Kanye fan.
I have this very complicated
feeling about Kanye now,
or have for
a very long time.
So, I was just like
listening to the music,
which is what
I was already doing,
and watching that meeting
a bunch,
and kind of seeing
where his points were
and how he felt, his intensity
and just trying to match
the things that were fun
for me to do.
I just had to watch it
over and over again
to the point where I was like
"he's not wrong
about everything."
Yeah.
Right. Right. Right.
Right.
Oh, so you were able
to become him
when you were able
to empathize with him
and see his perspective
so it wasn't like
"let me just find a way
to ridicule
this person
with my impression
but let me try to be him
and see where he's coming
from and attack
that impression from that?
Yeah. 100 percent.
I have too much empathy
for everything.
That's just kinda like a thing
I get from my grandma and my ma.
They pass that shit down,
so I care about things
that are really weird.
But, yeah.
For me, he's a rich guy
that became this headline guy.
He wants to bring
the world together.
He's just doing it wrong.
And doing it the way
a lot of us don't agree with
but everything
he's saying wasn't crazy like
Stop, Stop and Frisk
is like a thing.
Prison reform.
He's always been that way.
He's been more informed
in how to do it.
Now, he's just.
Yeah.
You can't say "I'm on the side
of the guy who has kids in cages
but this is fun
and we should do this."
It just feels like he wants
to be subversive to,
I don't know. He wants to
make headlines with stuff.
Yeah, he wants to do that.
It's like ego with good ideas
and no reading.
And bipolar disorder
that's not being
medically treated at the time.
He's not taking his meds.
He's not on his medication
but he also lies a little bit
so you don't know exactly
what he has, what he doesn't.
Let me ask you about
when you're actually working
on an impression,
was there a nuance
in his voice or a way
he said a certain word
where you're like
"I'm definitely gonna say
that word
because I can really nail that?"
Yeah, he has this thing where
he tries to hide his Chicago
but then it comes out
when he gets excited.
So, that growl like "You know."
That very guttural thing.
He tries to hide it
'cause he's talking
to white people.
So, he's trying to not hide it
but then it comes out anyways.
So, it was like watching two
people fight in the same throat.
Was there a line you
especially loved
saying because you were like,
'cause sometimes when I'm doing
an impression
there's a moment where I really
feel like I'm them.
I can only hold onto it
for a a second sometimes
and it frustrates me
and it's hard to maintain it.
How did you maintain it?
I'm still working on it.
I've done it.
The impression is maybe
two days old.
Yeah.
Like when he says stuff
like "time."
Those things I can dive
into real well.
I like playing with that and
just anytime he gets too hype.
That's the energy he puts onto
all of his albums.
Song, Kanye can do even better
than I can do.
You know what's fun to say
as him is
"Hurry up
with my damn croissant."
Hurry up with my damn croissant.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I love it.
I wanna make a song as him next
to help me tone that shit more.
What album were you
listening to to get-
Oh man, I was listening
to old Kanye.
Yes!
Which I listen
to most of the time.
Dark Twisted Fantasy
is just so perfect.
It's the perfect album.
Amazing. Front to back.
I think it started the Kanye
that we see,
though 'cause he put all
of his issues on that record
and people praised it.
So, then he's like
"No, people praise my crazy."
And that's just like,
I don't know.
We could talk about
ye all day.
Yeah.
I do think once he started
putting his weird thoughts
on record, new slaves
and all that shit like yesus,
we started just like "yeah,
we like you and your crazy."
He's like oh well,
I'm gonna be crazy
with something else
that you don't agree with.
Did you like yesus?
I love yesus.
I thought it was dope. I thought
it was a mental breakdown.
I think it's great.
I think it divided people.
That was the first
dividing line. Yeah.
I thought it was a breakdown
over Beats
but I thought
it was a genius.
You know what came up in shuffle
for me
yesterday at the best time?
I was working out
and it was Kanye's workout plan?
That song is so fun!
When those strings come in.
Oh, I love it so much.
Dude, Jesus walks
is one of my favorite.
Oh my God.
It just makes you wanna "Yeah."
It was like right around
the time where hip hop was like
"don't talk about Jesus and God
when you're doing hip hop."
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yep.
And then Kanye was like
"I'm gonna do it."
But he's been the same guy
the whole time.
You know what I mean?
Like don't press the red button
and he presses the red button?
Exactly. He's just now choosing
the one side
that's pissing people off.
But that's always been him.
Yeah.
Yep.
You just wish he just read
a book of some kind.
No honestly, though.
It's not even-
What book would you rec,
if you could come up
with Kanye's-
"One Fish, Two Fish,
Red Fish, Blue Fish."
Red Fish, Blue Fish.
That's the Democratic party
and the Republican party
if you just.
Any book.
Any book by any author.
So, what has been the most
unexpected part of
working at SNL for you?
You walk in, we would
all walk into SNL with
"I think I know what this is
gonna be, I've read the books,
I've heard the interviews",
what was the most
unexpected thing for you?
The most unexpected
was how cool Lorne is.
He's like an Old G.
I'm used to old school,
like gangsta types
and he's very much that.
He's very nice dude and there's
a lot of other things that,
he's just knows there's
so many stories
about him that he's like,
"you can't stop them all."
That's a great Lorne.
Everybody has their
good version of Lorne.
I thought I was gonna
get fired so much.
I realized that wasn't like,
you're not gonna get as fired
as much as you think you are.
But, also you could.
But, also.
Yeah, you definitely could.
You know what I saw?
Did you see Lorne on Norm
MacDonald's show?
Oh, I haven't seen that yet. No.
I haven't seen that yet.
I really recommend watching it
because I've always thought
of him as someone to fear
and I'm just like this guys
seems mean for no reason
and just like stuck up.
There's never been a part of me
that's like
"I can't wait to meet
Lorne Michael some day.
He just seems like frightening."
But, he is so sweet
and funny and soft.
Yeah, he's so cool.
He was like that on WTF, too.
He was Maron's podcast.
I was like oh,
it's not what I thought.
It's not what you think.
He's so dope. He's a dope dude
and he runs a super crazy
powerful business
which is dope just to watch
and be a part of, I guess.
And the crowd, the stage.
I thought it was
gonna be a lot bigger
and a lot more intimidating
and it's not.
When I've been to SNL, the one
time I went when Amy hosted,
it felt like going to see
my friend
in a play at the high school.
That's what it felt like again.
It gave me that same like
"Oh my God,
I can't believe my friend is",
but it's like watching a play.
It definitely is.
It's so fun.
That's so cool.
It's so crazy.
Now, the cold open
was nerve racking like crazy
'cause I knew
what it meant to the show
and I'm playing along side
Alec who I know
is gonna kill it.
Right in front of me
and I'm like
Oh, man.
So, I was just hoping,
and nothing
felt good until live.
Live just start to felt alright
'cause I knew
where the laughs were.
Live was like oh, okay.
I feel, I feel better.
Yeah.
I feel like you've reached
this point now where,
as comedians and as artists
we always just think
we're tricking everyone
to thinking we're talented
and people are like
we've tricked the system.
I shouldn't be doing
this right now.
But when you get on SNL,
they make so many good decisions
and they have a track record
of making great decisions.
Do you at that point go,
"Okay, I am good?"
Yeah.
Like this is validating enough
to be like
I should be here right now.
I'm gonna come out
and nail this.
Does it give you that sense
[crosstalk].
Yeah, that imposter syndrome
has started
to slip away a little bit.
Good!
'Cause at first it was very much
like I'm a student of the game
and I'm just learning
how to move in this.
You know what I mean?
Now,
I'm just gonna try to figure
what I want my legacy to be,
just try to up
myself every time.
And come in here
and just try to kill it
and bring what I bring
to the show.
Yeah.
I feel way more comfortable.
This second year is like breeze.
Anybody coming into
the show, man.
Just get through the first year.
You're straight.
I mean, I'm not gonna say
you're straight.
Shit, there has been hard years.
I've seen people
have hard years.
You know?
Yeah.
And they tell me all the time
"you're here
for some good times."
Right. Right.
I wasn't there when Trump
was there.
There's a lot of things
that happened.
The show could go
any way any time,
which is something I like
about it.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Well,
the imposter syndrome thing
that I always go back to,
a therapist once said to me,
she was like
"who do you think you are
that you're tricking everyone?
Do you think that these people
are stupid?"
When you're on SNL, you're
dealing with Lorne Michaels.
He's made the smartest
comedy decisions.
Right.
If you were able to trick him
and weasel your way on the sh,
you know.
If Lorne Michael's picks you,
it's validating of "okay,
I am talented."
Yeah.
And I'm glad you got that
because you are.
Thank you so much.
It's so exciting to see you
become famous and dress better.
You just look richer.
Yo, dressing better
is like so important.
You look rich now.
You walk into a club
and I'm like
"Chris Redd's rich."
Or at least successful.
I was just wearing the same
clothes for so long,
people aren't used
to seeing me do shit.
I know. I can't wait.
My friend gave me this shirt.
It's true.
No, I didn't know you that well.
But, you just know
when someone's on SNL.
One thing about the show.
It's like a fashion show
for some of us.
Oh, yeah.
I want to be the flies
at all times.
What? And Chase always flies.
Sam J is always flies.
Get Rich dude,
one of the writers always flies.
So, we just kinda like,
we're always coming in
with new shit, new shoes
and she's like
"look what I got."
It's one thing like people
just assume you're a Democrat
because you're on the show,
which is a very weird thing
'cause I'm like I'm not
in any political games.
I don't really care that much.
I vote for who makes
sense to me.
But, people just put you in like
"oh, you're this
or you're that."
Everybody on the show
is not one or the other
but a lot of the write
makes it seems like.
I'm like a lot of things
I write aren't even
political in the show.
I'm writing
socially political stuff.
It has nothing to do with
the shit you guys talk about.
But, they put you in that box
which is very weird
'cause they feel like
they're in a box.
So, everybody is in a box,
putting other people in boxes
and there's just a bunch
of boxes running around.
Everybody gets so intense
and serious about SNL
and they criticize it like
I give a fuck.
Right. Right.
We ain't been funny in 45 years.
Oh, that!
Well you don't have
the real picture, sir.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I can't stand that.
They've been saying
that since year one.
Yeah, dog.
It was funny last year.
That's been funny since '75.
Yeah.
People are the worst
but you want people talking
about the show in any way.
Right.
I mean, that's what
keeps it alive.
We gotta go to break but
I can't wait to spend another,
will you stick around?
I'm chillin. I'm chillin, man.
Okay, I can't wait. Thank you.
Chris Redd is here, everyone.
We are back in studio
right now with
That Thakkar, Ian Fidance,
and Chris Redd from SNL.
Chris, so excited
to have you in.
So excited to be here.
I love me some Nikki Glaser.
Oh my God, I love me
some Chris Redd.
We just become friends I would
say right before you got SNL.
Yeah, dog.
I kind of like became buds
with you
Yeah, I think it was in L.A.
and then you were gone.
We were gonna go to dinner
in L.A. together
I know, dude.
and you're like "I'm moving."
Yeah, it was crazy.
We had planned to go to lunch
and then I had to move quick
and couldn't say why.
So, I just had to dip
and I was like
"I feel like an asshole
'cause I had so many
different plans that week.
I had finally
started liking L.A.
I finally starting
finding friend groups
I really like to fuck with
and then I had to just leave.
And then I couldn't say
nothing for a week.
So, what'd you tell people?
Dog, I just didn't.
Well, I'm not a great
text backer anyway,
several people will say that.
Oh, really?
Yeah. I mean, no.
I answer you all the time.
Yeah, you're pretty good
with me.
Yeah but I'm generally
not great at it.
So, for some people
I could just not say anything
and then once the news
came out they're like
"oh, I get it."
And I'm like yeah.
Some people who I,
comics get like an in with me
'cause it's usually something
I'm dealing with right away.
I'm gonna see you out
so I'm gonna definitely hit you
back because you're a comic.
But, if it's like
a regular person,
I ain't got time
to talk to regular people.
That's crazy.
Well, talking about
dating and stuff.
It's so difficult.
I've seen you on the celebrity
dating app, Raya.
Oh, yeah?
I think you're still active
on there
even if you don't wanna be.
Yeah, I mean
it's like off my phone.
Oh no, it might still be
on my phone, honestly.
That's the thing with these
dating apps,
you take them off your phone
but you're still on there.
Yeah.
You have to go disable
your account.
The way I jumped on those apps
is not believable.
It's very true.
I did this social experiment
with the Moses Storm,
like four years ago,
and my caret-
It was like a half prank show,
half written scripted
and so what we were
trying to do
is have people come
to this red light
that was a text friendly light.
It lasted a lot longer so people
can get their texts out.
So, the whole thing
was my character
was like the serial dater.
So, I jumped on all the apps
to get people to come
to this street
so we can fuck with them
at this text friendly light.
So, after that I just
stayed on all the apps
'cause I didn't really
give a shit
and then I got addicted
to just swiping.
It's an addiction. Yeah.
So, anytime I would be on tour,
I would see how ugly
is this city?
And I would play that game
for a while.
And then I just have the apps
sometimes on these apps.
So, people tell me
all the time I'm on them
but I don't really use them
that much at all.
I don't mind being seen on them.
Everyone is like
"Well, you're a celebrity
and what if people see?"
I'm just like so-
Yeah, who cares.
If they see you in the world,
what's the difference?
And you can't talk.
You're not gonna meet up
with me any quicker.
I'm just still an image
on your phone that is not,
maybe,
but, now though with Instagram,
that's how i think
people can get in touch
with celebrities
if you want, slide into-
Nothing is preventing you
from sending me a message
and me maybe seeing it.
I've met more people
off of Instagram
than any dating app, dog.
Yeah. That's the way.
Not even for a date.
Just like, yo, I'm doing shows,
can I show whatever.
And it feels so much smoother.
It does. It's the same thing.
It's the same exact thing.
Yeah. It is the same.
It's exactly the same.
It's like okay cupid
or whatever
because you don't have
to match with them.
You can just reach out
and message people.
Yeah. The other day
Padma Lakshmi slid into my DM's
and asked me to a show that
she's putting on in Brooklyn
and I was like,
I can't believe Padma.
I would have missed her message
had I not gone
to that weird folder
that has the other ones?
Right.
Oh, I go to the other ones
all the.
The other ones is
a good name for it.
Yeah.
The other ones.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
And you look for a blue check?
You look for a blue check
so that there's someone
that's like important and rich.
Not rich, I don't care
about money. You do.
Or you look for someone
to say
something in those
first couple lines
'cause all you can see
are the first lines.
Right.
Or you try to look
at the tiniest
avatar to see
if they're attractive.
Is it worth it for them to know
I've read this.
Yeah.
That's so funny.
Yes. Yes.
But, I mean, that's the new way
everyone is meeting each other
including celebrities, whoever.
Instagram's the new dating app.
Did you go on dates
from dating apps?
Have you ever been on one?
Yo, so I went on, Oh my God,
I went on one from Bumble.
Yo, and it was this girl
who I met
but it took us about a year
to actually go out
'cause I was on tour.
Right. Right. Right.
Every time I was back
in New York
I only had like a day and I was
like I'm not gonna rush around.
Yeah, with a stranger. Right.
Yeah. That would be crazy.
So, at the end of this summer
is actually when
we went out on a date.
I took her to Soho House.
Are you a member?
Yeah.
Dude. Will you take me sometime?
Of course.
Or will you just
recommend me?
Anytime.
Great. It's so cool.
Dude, we did that show there.
I felt like they were gonna
kick me out afterwards.
Yes, I know. You had
I don't be in Soho House energy.
I loved it.
I loved it, dog.
No, but that show's awesome.
That show's always pretty fun.
Yeah, it was a fun time.
How long have you been
a member of Soho House?
And for those
that don't know,
Soho House is just this
like exclusive, cool place
to go hang out, have meetings,
get work done, there's a gym,
there's a restaurant,
there's apartments.
It's just a place
you can go.
When you go there, you pay
full price for everything
but to be a member of it,
to even be able to dine there
or get a drink there
or have a meeting there,
you have to pay
I think it's $3,000 a year
to be a member.
It's like a city country club
or some shit.
Yes.
It is.
Yeah, kind of.
It totally is.
But I would go to the one
in Chicago
and do shows
and in the one in L.A.
and then they were like
"If you do one more show for us,
we'll make you a member."
That started a couple years ago.
That's like a stamp card
in a fucking coffee shop.
Exactly, I was like "okay, damn.
Let me get my promo stamps."
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Then, when I got to Lulo,
Yasmine was one of
the directors over there
or still is
and I did her show.
She was like "Yeah,
we gotta make you a member."
I was like, yeah,
I wanna throw shows in here
because there's not enough
black people in here.
So, I wanna throw more shows.
That was kind of like the goal.
And it still is.
I take advantage of it a lot.
I love that spot.
It's very low key.
What a great date place, too.
So, you brought this girl
to Soho house.
Yeah, we had these drinks.
The drinks are amazing there
and we're sitting there
and I'm like just
getting to know her
and I'm realizing
she doesn't ask any questions.
She's like "I don't really talk.
I'm just.
Everybody says
I'm mysterious."
Oh, this girl was so hot.
You're boring.
I'm like, what?
You're the most boring person
I've ever met in my life.
How hot was she, though?
She was kinda hot.
I mean, so hot!
To get away with that type
of personality
That's the thing.
She wasn't that banging
where it was like, come on.
You gotta have some opinions
about something.
She was acting like
she belonged at Soho House
but she's only living
at Equinox.
She's not like a prototype
of a person at Soho House.
She sounded like she plugged
herself up before she go to bed.
Just like a robot.
I was like, so what do you do?
Do men just talk and you
just listen the whole time?
She's like "
Yeah, pretty much."
I'm like that's stupid.
I don't wanna do that.
A hot therapist?
That works a lot for, I mean,
that's a technique
that I've read about in books
where it's like
how to get a guy,
it's just listen,
don't talk, shut up.
You can start talking once
you're in a relationship
but shut up before then
because men just wanna talk
and be heard.
I hate that.
Please don't cosmopolitan
article me lady.
Yeah. I hate that.
I don't need this.
I wanna talk to a person.
I already have ten sexy ways
to get abs.
Yo, for real.
Sexy abs? I have gross abs.
Gross abs?
Yeah, that's a bad date.
So, how did it-
Did she know who you
were before hand?
Oh, I think she knew me
from Disjointed.
That's what took me a long time
to even go out with her
in the first place
'cause it was just like
I don't wanna do this.
Why? What are you in Disjointed?
I play this weed head.
Oh, okay.
People just, I don't know.
They assume you're like
your character.
Yeah, or I wanna talk about
that the whole time.
Right.
Yeah, and they don't know
you at all.
At all.
Yeah, they just know you
from t- like,
they just know you as
a character so that's not you.
Yeah, it's like a weird energy.
I just don't. Yeah.
Sometimes it's very weird.
I knew she was gonna be weird
going in
but I had a free night.
Yeah.
I kinda wanted to see
what it is.
I've kinda been putting it off
for a minute
and she was kind of fun
to talk to on
like back and forth
texting every now and then.
Yeah, sometimes you get
someone who is a good texter
and then you're like
why are you such a dud?
We should just
text each other.
This is why I say get off
the app as fast as possible
'cause then you find out.
'Cause some people will waste
your time texting forever
and then you're like
"Oh, this was such a waste."
Yeah, I hate the apps.
Although, I did get
recognized on Grinder.
So, that's.
You did?
You got recognized on Grind?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
From a torso.
A picture of a guys torso
and he was like "I'm a fan."
I like to think it is
just his torso
and then he started
a Grinder account.
I bet you've been recognized
from Grinder before.
I bet that's where
most people see.
You're the guy who asked
how my butt hole's doing.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I can only get
recognized from this.
Look like a glory hole face.
Glory hole face.
Yeah, Glory hole
face recognition.
Glory hole's are so disgusting.
It's so disgusting.
It's such a crazy concept
to put your most
precious item of your body
in a hole that you don't
know on the other side.
Talk about fear of intimacy.
That is literally
the most un-intimate thing
you can do to be
completely blocked off.
It's like what you want to do
though
where it's like a guy
in a mask or whatever.
I'm so into glory hole porn
because I'm scared of intimacy.
You're into glory
hole relationships.
Yo, wait. Why?
I like, all the porn I watch,
I'd have to say it's like
a woman being used by a guy.
Why do I like glory hole?
Because the woman's
just like a hole.
A vessel.
And she's not like a person,
and I don't want
to be not a person
but I want to distance it.
Sex for me is so weird
and it's just so,
I have to disassociate to engage
in it because it is so.
You're like naked
and you're like.
No, you're just sober
so you're aware of it.
Yeah, I'm sober.
She fucks like Elaine dances.
I kind of do.
When I'm squirming around.
I like the maracas though.
That shit's dope.
But, sex is so weird.
It's so strange that you could
be at dinner
with someone having
a conversation at Soho House
and then cut two, like boom,
yoU guys are naked.
For the first time,
it's so weird.
It's so dope.
Oh weird, I mean.
I love it, man.
It rules. Sex rules.
Of course it's so great
but to get to
Yeah, sex is pretty cool,
I guess.
Sex is pretty cool.
Who's dad is this?
Sex is pretty fly.
You kids having sex?
You guys doing intercourse?
You know, I had sex once.
Right, son? Right, son?
Ew , dad.
I was always so fascinated by-
I'll show you the pictures.
Before I hooked up
and I was a late bloomer
so all my friends were
hooking up before me
and I was always so fascinated
by how do you go
from doing nothing
to doing that?
What is the transition?
You can't ask.
You can't be like be like
"can we have sex now?"
There's gotta be a move.
I'm so uncomfortable
with that transition
and whenever my friends
get prostitutes I'm always like
"do they walk in and comment
on your sconces
and then they take off
all their clothes?"
How do you move
from just being hello.
I always ask them if they want
something from Seven Eleven.
Do you really?
Yeah. Yeah. Then I bring them
a red bull and a snack.
You leave them alone
in your apartment?
No, I go to them.
Oh, you go to them and you
bring them,
that's what I do
with my uber driver's
when they drop me off at
Seven Eleven.
When I make them stop,
I go "do you want anything?"
So it makes them feel better
and they never do.
And sometimes when they do,
I go "really?
I have to buy you
something now?
I know it was an offer,
but I didn't mean it."
The transition is fun.
It's the fun part.
What's your go to?
Can we give people
listen some tips?
'Cause I think that
there's some,
a lot of people have anxiety
about that first moment.
What's your first move?
What's your go to?
Well, I-
Pretend it's Kanye.
Yeah. Yeah. First of all,
I do it as Kanye.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't know if I have a move
but it's like a tale
when you know it's going down.
Like "Hey, you wanna go back
to the house and chill
and watch a movie
or something."
That's a very standard
old way to do it.
I did not know
that that meant sex.
For so long I was sitting
and watching "Almost Famous."
But also have a movie ready,
fam. You gotta have a movie.
Don't just go there like,
lights out.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
You gotta go through the motions
like you
don't know it's happening.
You know what I mean.
'Cause that's generally
the way to do it.
[crosstalk] gotcha.
I don't even have a TV.
Or an apartment. All right.
Load up your phone.
Get in that box.
That is kidnapping.
That's a Netflix gift card
dangling.
That's a good one.
The, just come back
to my apartment.
We all know what that means.
We're having a good time,
let's keep this going
and go somewhere private.
The time makes sense too.
Right?
'Cause if it's like 1AM,
I don't wanna stop hanging out.
That's where it initiates.
Almost like hanging out
but if you gotta go home,
I could take you home.
And then, depending on
how the energy is,
right, is kind of dependent on
if you're gonna get down or not.
What about, like I went on
a date
with a guy not too long ago
and we didn't know
if it was a date or not,
it was like friends hanging out
and then we were at dinner
and then we were like, let's go
walk over here and get dessert.
Now, let's walk over here
and get tea.
Now, let's,
and it got to the point
to where it was like okay,
and we both,
and he didn't ask me over
and we're just standing
on the corner,
I'm calling an uber,
and I'm like are we gonna kiss?
It was so awkward.
Then my Uber shows up
and I'm like bye
and I just get in a getaway car
and I run away.
In a getaway car.
There could have been a moment
where he could have kissed me
or something
but it was too awkward for us
to both handle on the street.
Somebody's gotta do it.
Somebody's gotta make a move.
Yeah. I make a move.
I don't wait for it.
Yeah. I've been making the move.
It feels good.
But, I've been rejected before.
Being rejected
is part of the game.
Yeah. Hey, swing and miss.
That's okay.
No, all right.
I was just kidding.
Dude, one time I got rejected
and I pulled up a kid swinging
and missing in a t-ball game
and was like "look it's me."
That's great.
I moon walked away. I did.
I did.
Because it's funny as hell.
Why not.
That's so fucking funny.
That's so funny.
Yeah. I'll moon walk.
Fuck that shit.
That's so great.
Just do the robot.
System shut down.
Boner disengaged.
Yeah, just so she don't feel
weird for making a decision
she has every right to make.
I don't think I've ever had
a guy go in
where I didn't want him to.
I think I'm very good about
putting out the energy
of don't kiss me right now
if I don't want it.
I just give them no oppor-
You've never had anybody
try where you're like
"I didn't want
to do that."
No.
Wow.
I think I'm pretty good at,
not to say that women who do
have guys that try to kiss them
Yeah, well they're asking
for it.
Exactly.
Well, guys,
maybe you should be better
about putting it out there
if you don't want it.
Change your outfit.
There's energy though. There's
definitely energy to pick up on.
My favorite energy
of new relationships is when
Oh my God, yes,
Dr. Drew is back.
Hell, yeah.
Getting a selfie.
Look at you, cutie.
I forgot to do that.
Look at that.
I love you. The best energy
ever is when you.
Okay, so say Ian and I
were hanging out at a show
or something and we're sitting
next to each other
and we're not even on a date.
It's just like a guy
I'm sitting next to that
"oh, i could be into him."
This has happened to me recently
and I love it.
Where you accidentally touch
but you won't take it away.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm (affirmative).
I love those moments.
I love it because you know
if I wasn't into,
Ian I could do like this
'cause he's my friend,
but if I wasn't into a guy
that is just my friend
or just someone that
I would never be, we would touch
and I would instantly be like
"oh, that's our space."
But, when you just leave it
and they leave it
and you go "conformation."
Yeah.
It's not even just a point
on your arm
where you do your whole arm
is flush with them.
Yeah. I love this.
And it's like we have
all the room not to do this
right now,
that's the hottest thing.
That's what's fun figuring out
where people stand,
how you feel about somebody.
Those little moments.
I love that shit.
But, seriously,
get away from me.
Yeah. It's making me
uncomfortable looking at you.
Yeah, it is weird.
I'm like, do you need help?
Or if you're saying hi
to someone.
The other night,
there was this guy
that I had some energy with
and so we were saying hi.
We were greeting everyone
and I kinda just like held
on a little bit longer.
Oh.
You just give little indications
like that.
Oh, that's what you were
doing to me.
I get it.
Yeah, I like you Nikki.
I may have done that to you.
Here, you sit here
and redo that whole.
Yeah.
I love those little things
but I will say the best,
and I'd give this advise
to every guy
who doesn't know
how to make a first move.
The best first move
I've ever had pulled on me
was on the street
one of those like
we're both going
our separate ways,
is there gonna be a kiss,
it's the end of the night.
I was just kind of like
staring at the ground
and he just goes
"get over here."
And he just grabs
my wrist gently
Yeah.
And kind of tugged me and it was
like the hottest thing.
But he said it like he was
in mortal combat?
Get over here.
Yeah. You gotta go in confident.
Yeah, but just like the,
what are we doing?
He goes "just get over here."
It was just the way,
I really recommend that move.
It's so hot. It's aggressive,
but not too aggressive.
It really is a perfect move
that I recommend.
And if he comes too fast,
you say "Whoopsy."
You gotta do that. Because life
is comedy and mortal combat.
Chris Redd, you were so great.
Thank you so much for coming in
on such a short notice.
Dude, this is awesome, man.
You are so funny and so fun
and I cant wait to watch you
just get more
and more successful.
Killer stand up.
Thank you so much.
If you haven't seen Chris Redd
in the movie "Pop Star",
please watch him in that.
He is a break out star in it.
But, that movie is so good.
I recommend it so much.
I got shows.
I got shows at Caroline's.
Tonight through Saturday.
Come out and hang out with me.
I'm talking all the shits.
Oh my God, you have to go see
Chris Redd
live at Caroline's this weekend
through Saturday,
starting tonight.
Chris Redd, thank you so much.
Ian Fidance,
how's your butt hole?
It's amazing. What a great show.
And That Thakkar, I love you.
Love you. [crosstalk]
I'm gonna be in Philly all week.
Come to shows.
Please come see me
at Philadelphia Punch Line.
Bye.